اليوم موضوعنا اقتصادي ومهم جدا هو في صلب
تفاصيل حياتنا اللي هو البطاقه البنكيه
هذه الشريحه اللي نستخدمها يوميا في
مصاريفنا بحثنا
بالفعل مشاهدينا اهميه هذه البطاقه تكمن
في سريتها ان تدفع دون ان تظهر تظهر ما
معك من اموال وتخبئ اموالك في مكان اخر
وهي وسيله دفع فقط لكن راوي اليوم اليوم
مع التطورات الكبيره في عالم التكنولوجيا
خصوصا فيما يتعلق بالاختراق التهكير يبدون
امام معضله تسمى باسورد رقم السري بالفعل
بالضبط يعادل لانه اليوم هناك
كبيره حول هذا الرمز وسؤال كبير دائم ايضا
هل اربع ارقام كافيه لان نكون امنين من
اختراق حساباتنا والسطو عليها
[موسيقى]
عوامل كثيره تشير الى تفوق وسيله الدفع
بالبطاقه البنكيه على الوسائل الاخرى
فاكثر من 25 مليار بطاقه بنكيه يمتلكها
الناس حتى نهايه العام الماضي 2022 وهناك
توقعات بوصول العدد الى اكثر من 28 مليار
بطاقه بنكيه عالميا هذه البطاقات اصبحت
اسلوب حياه بالنسبه لكثيرين لدرجه ان
ملايين الاشخاص يحملون في محفظتهم بطاقه
او اكثر احيانا لاجل تعاملاتهم البنكيه
وبحسب الخبراء فان الكثيرين يعتبرون هذه
البطاقه الممغنطه اكثر امانا من اساليب
الدفع الاخرى الهاتفيه او غيرها حتى يرى
الناس ان سرقه هواتفهم قد تمنح المحتلين
فرصه لسرقه حساباتهم المصرفيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في الاستوديو مدير التسويق في
شركه اكس انا مش عارفه اقول ايه
اسم الشركه نذير
نينوى اهلا بك استاذ نذير معنا صباح الخير
صباح النور
موضوع كبير موضوع البطاقات الائتمانيه
كلنا عنا بطاقات ائتمانيه واعتقد اغلبنا
مش عارفين كيف نستعملها بالطريقه المسلى
وشو كيف تصرفنا ايضا في حال انه تعرضنا
للسرقه
من حساب البطاقه الائتمانيه شو بنقدر نعمل
في هاي الحاله من حالات تعرض للسرقه
لبطاقات الائتمانيه حالات دوريه تحصل ممكن
كل ساعه
فالبنوك عندها طرق اجرائيه سريعه جدا في
الحالات هذه فعاده عند سرقه البطاقه او
الشك في السرقه هناك طرق لازم الشخص
يتبعها اول طريقه وقف البطاقه عن طريق
مكالمه البنك عندهم خط ساخن
او عن طريق الابليكيشن مغلب البنوك عندها
فيك توقف البطاقه رح يقدر يسترجع الدروس
اللي سرقت في حال لاسترجاع الفلوس هناك
اجراءات ثانيه تاخذها البنك وكذلك الشخص
يتم اول شيء مثلا المفروض الشخص ساكن في
الامارات مثلا وما سافر لبلد معين ويلاقون
انه هالعمليات شراء تمت من بلد معين
فيعرفوا انه اكيد هي عمليه احتيال كذلك لا
تنسي ان هناك ناس كثير بتحاول تحتال على
البنوك كذلك فالبنك لازم يتاكد من من
عمليه طيب خليني اسالك عن
الرقم السري اربع ارقام يكفون ولا لا
والله لو كانوا حتى 20 رقم ممكن ما يكفي
لو لو تم الاحتيال بتطبيق معين يعني لا
اربع على سته ولا عشرين طيب اليوم حتى
احنا لما نستخدم البطاقه الائتمانيه ونذهب
ما في ثلاث ارقام سي سي
بثلاث ارقام هذه هي اللي من الممكن يتحصل
اي مكان او اي محل تجاري على الرقم وعلى
اسمي ومن ثم هذه الثلاث ارقام يستخدم
البطاقه
الائتمانيه هل هو تناقض في هذا النظام ولا
ايش حقيقه ممكن ناس كثيره تسال انه هل
الكرت تبعي يكون مخزن عادي عند اي محل
عاده هذا الموضوع لا يمكن لانه عمليه
البيع تكون عن طريق زي ما انت شايف اللي
تكون عند صاحب المحل تكون من بنك معروف
فهو على طول يكون مخزن حتى المكان اللي
انت تشتريه منه ما انت بعض الاماكن يطلبوا
منك البطاقه نفسها الرقم برقم البطاقه
والاسم
والثلاث ارقام بالخلف هذه كل معلومات
البطاقه بالطبع هذه هي هنا الكارثه
استخدام البطاقه في مواقع غير معروفه هنا
هنا الموضوع لازم يكون عنده حملات توعويه
كبيره لازم الانسان يفهم وين يقدر يستخدم
بطاقته يعني مواقع معروفه اللي هي الناس
كلها تعرفها محميه اغلب هذه المشاكل بتصير
لما الواحد بيشتري اونلاين يعني من مواقع
الكترونيه اون لاين وممكن لانها بتخزن
معلوماتنا معلومات البطاقه الائتمانيه
ولكن مش بالضروره انها تكون امنه انا حبيت
اسال هل هناك طرق اخرى للدفع
يعني طريق طرق لاستخدام البطاقه
الائتمانيه ولكن بدون ما تكون البطاقه معك
يعني بشكل فعلي هل هناك طرق اخرى وهل في
المستقبل احنا راح نصير نستخدم هذه الطرق
الاخرى اكثر على حساب البطاقات الائتمانيه
حاليا هناك اكيد طرق اخرى هناك ملوك
الكترونيه هناك بعض الابلكيشن زي ما انت
حكيتي
في فيكي تشبكي الكرت تبعك على التليفون
على طول لكن لازلتي تستخدمين نفس البطاقه
لان هي نفس البطاقه مشبوكه لكن هناك بنوك
ثانيه زي باي بال فيك تشحني الحساب تبعك
لو انت خايفه انك تستخدمي كرت على طول فيك
على طول تشبكيه بالكارت نرجع لنفس الموضوع
فالكرود دائما سيتم استخدامها يعني حتى
اذا كانت الكترونيه تطلع لك وحده ثانيه في
مبلغ اللي هو مدفوع بالضبط شكرا لمدير
التسويق في شركات اكس تي بي نام نذير
نينوى شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات